all right Logan yes sir Logan uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
I grew up in California Bakersfield in
California
um
I we moved whenever I was 11.
we moved to uh Odessa Texas
uh whenever I was 11 my dad's job
Bakersfield it's an Old Town
and we moved to Odessa Texas Midland
Area uh
because of his job at the time how'd you
describe your childhood
roughly or like yes all right I think
like he
I mean I don't have like a
horrible childhood I don't think like I
don't remember anything gnarly nothing
really in high school
uh I mean I was I I didn't graduate I
dropped out a sophomore year I think and
I just went to work you know everyone in
my family my cousins even my mother's in
oilfield everyone is so I just left so
you worked in the oil fields yes sir
yeah that's what I what I was gonna do
that's why I dropped out was just
everyone there's so much money in it
like
why is why stay in school and go in debt
in college when I mean I was 17 making
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
working in the oil field we're gonna
know if you're working hard and you're
not you're not having fun you're getting
dirty on a rig but you know I was a case
or and I won't I can't say the name but
um
yeah Workforce was great it treated me
good I got paid really well
um you know I had four four cars you
know I had everything I ever wanted and
I had any I would go buy brands in
stores
uh as happy and my all my family we've
all made money we were doing great and
uh yeah of course I I dropped that and I
I mean I had fun with my money I didn't
I was a kid I didn't know uh like what
to do with it I didn't invest a dollar
one of the things you like to do with it
was Skydive correct
yes sir uh well I started skydiving
relatively
like it's pretty new for me I'm not I'm
not a professional Scott ever first and
foremost like how old are you I'm 28
right now sir I started jumping whenever
it was it hasn't even been a year
whenever I had my first Skydive but
whenever you become a student at schools
I mean you can I mean at least the one I
can only speak for one because I was
only at one but uh
yeah you can jump as much as much as
that plane's going you can go you know I
mean what was your goal with it to uh to
just have fun or you want to become an
instructor I wanted to be an instructor
yeah
most some people I forget I don't know
it's in a movie there's a quote but some
people do this thing they
for this feeling they do certain things
some people rob places or people some
people do drugs some people do whatever
you know my fix was the sky the
adrenaline dump that you get from just
taking one step there it's so easy and
it's so much fun like right now even
with everything considered like I would
still go
that was my
crystal meth I would
I dropped everything for it my my me and
my old lady Meg she we moved to San
Antonio to be just closer because we
were in Odessa I had a good job she had
a job there everything was fine we were
making money doing good just quit it all
leave
and to go jump I want that's all I
wanted she supported me in that and she
thank God she's a nurse you know she can
help me in that and she can get a job
anywhere but
so you got into skydiving tell me what
happened to you uh
three months ago this summer uh I got
into skydiving because of my girl she
took me for my first tandem for her
birthday she's already been and from
there it was his love at first sight I
loved it from the moment I would drive
four hours every week and to go jump
um and recently uh
and about three months ago give or take
I had an accident I I
was on my last jump for graduation for
my a license and that's really a super
new skydiver
uh it's about 25 jumps and that's a lot
to someone who has never jumped I
understand that but I've personally met
somebody with 12 000 jumps so 25 is
nothing to they do that in a weekend
anyway
um
it was just like any normal the last
jump It's supposed to be your fun jump
you you tell it that's the first time
really you tell the instructor
what you're gonna do and you've learned
everything that he had to show you you
learned how to flip you learned how to
swoop and duck you learned how to do
things such as
you know I didn't play and just to prove
to you proved to him already you can do
it safely
and I did I proved him uh enough that he
was confident and uh he let me go many
jumps before
and this one I just told him hey man I
just want to do flips I want to you know
I love doing the fronts and back flips
and you have about a minute of free fall
and you're falling at 120 miles an hour
and you at that point they allowed me to
wear a face shield uh it's just a it's
kind of like a if you could describe
it's just like a like a street bike
helmet so to speak but it's a little bit
rised up in the back anyway
um I'm falling
everything's fine uh I had a time in my
life the minute goes on it feels like a
um it feels like five minutes it feels
like a good long time
I got to deployment time 4K I waved and
I said see ya
and whenever I did that uh
please mind you I'm of the
my father and the instructors came to
see me in the hospital and they told me
what happened I haven't watched the
video myself I have a there's a video I
can't bring myself to watch it but uh
uh they explained everything that
happened to me and if I do get that I
might have to pause just for a second
but
um
when I deployed I just had a misfire my
parachute deployed and I'm good
and then they said I looked over and I
have two parachutes up
um that's fine we trained for that
before every jump it doesn't matter if
it's our first or 25th word practice in
our EPs and I know what that is
and side by side it happens you know
these are equipment that gets jumped
multiple times every single day and it's
packed by a human it wasn't by me it was
by a person trained to do these things
and so I see it and okay we got we got a
problem and it's usually really easy you
you uh untoggle which pretty much means
put it in Drive
and you
very very gently you don't do sharp
turns or flares all the way down nothing
like that you just go you know you just
land wherever you're going that's where
you're going and you got to think like
you have two massive pieces of fabric on
top of you
well
unfortunately
I had a situation where it got worse
it's called a down plane and what
happens is
I don't know if it was a win that caused
it or if I messed up personally if I
messed up personally
but uh
it started a downplay which means it
separates which means there's no fabric
now on top of my head
and maybe at this point when final
whenever every all the fabric is over my
head I probably lost about a thousand
foot in give or take I don't know I
wasn't looking at my altimeter after 4K
so
I don't know where I was at I couldn't I
don't remember that part anyway
and my instructor was above me or below
me because he didn't pull at my time
um
he pulls below me to make sure that I'm
deployed unless he had to come up to me
and deploy my stuff to save my life it's
his job but I was deployed he went down
below and he and in the video you can
see me uh there's two and
anyway I got a down plane
uh
at that point they told me that I cut
away which you're supposed to do you're
supposed to you can't usually at normal
would be cut away a poor Reserve but my
Reserve is already out your cutaway
handles here and your reserves here
I cut away I punched pulled
like I was supposed to do I was trained
to do that and uh
when I did that
um apparently my parachute wanted to go
into my
reserve and now I have no there's
nothing above my head nothing
and uh
I mean you
I can't I fell from Pro I would if I had
to guess maybe like
2500 to 2 000 feet ish I don't know and
the speed no one was right next to me I
don't know how I mean I could use my
imagination I had a
um a shirt probably above my head
because there was no two open canopies
open one was trying I'm sure but it had
another canopy inside of it so it's just
mangled mesh
at that point
uh I imagine
I mean that again his memories were
taken from me I don't
it's just a defense mechanism I think no
one wants to know what happened after
that but you don't recall any
oh my God I'm gonna die moment
uh mainly in the hospital
um
from the point of I first before you go
into that tell me what you hit before
when you hit the ground
oh I I had um luckily close to my DZ
where my drop zone is where I where I
that plane took off
there's an area where
we come up before a jump I forgot to
mention is a landing pattern
when we jump we jump at a very specific
time before we leave that play and I
know where that drop zone is
and I can look down from the plane and
see it clear as day okay cool there's
the runway we're good uh I'm jumping at
14 000 feet and I know that if I jump
and I deploy at 4K I can make I mean it
might take me a second to ice it okay
cool and then make my adjustments and
land where I landed whenever I had my
malfunction
uh was in a cornfield that was
relatively close close enough that
unfortunately or fortunately and
unfortunately for some they seen me hit
the ground they was it was just they
have a spotter out there to make sure
everyone makes it back
and I I made it back all right
thankfully close enough and I hit the
ground
when that happened they again thankfully
they send a Life Flight when a live
flight happens it's a helicopter in in
they had a helicopter come pick me up
and I was
I was in bad shape it was there was no
there's no sugar coat and it is I mean
it's
it was bad uh I had inside internal
hemorrhaging
from my spine
uh I was bleeding from the inside out I
was just I was bubbling up my my jaw
uh is broken in three places from the
impact and I was wearing a helmet so it
tells you like I could only imagine what
would I don't think I'd be if I didn't
have a helmet on uh
and I wasn't wearing it first and
foremost for protection I was wearing it
because it's comfortable keeps win daddy
rise you don't have to wear those goofy
goggles that are uncomfortable that
crush your face you put on Boom strap
and you're good I didn't wear it for
safety but thankfully it did its job but
yeah I broke my jaw here
and then it split down the middle here
um
I broke six ribs on and again whenever I
landed I forgot to say I landed on my
right side
I landed
um it's hard to describe but pretty much
just solely on this side of my body
completely and I don't know where my arm
was but it was damaged in the in the
fall too and I landed on my ribs in my
chest but I broke six ribs too and I
broke my sternum
uh I broke a toe somehow of course on my
right side
I severed a nerve in my back and
exploded my L3
um
and you bit your tongue yeah I I it's
it's probably hard to see but on both
sides of my tongue I didn't get it in
half or anything but I guess the impact
it just Jarred my mouth closed and my
tongue just so happened to come out at
the same time so if you stick your
tongue out and bite down on the sides
that's what happened the idea stitches
on my tongue and it sucked that was
horrible but
uh
yeah I had
um internal hemorrhaging of course
but thankfully they when I got to the
hospital they worked me up pretty good
they
they had me on a drip Dilaudid
um and I've never I've taken when like I
said I had fun as a kid
I did I I did my fair share of testing
you know certain substances out and
stuff I never really had a problem so to
speak there was one point in time I
thought I was going through withdrawals
I will say I have been through
withdrawals and it wasn't my choice per
se it was because of Dilaudid
uh
anyway
um
now now I'm in the hospital uh
and there's so many I'm I may be
forgetting something I
I I it's so many things happen to me and
that that short area and I it was just
three months ago yeah yeah it was very
yeah it was very early but
uh yeah it was quite a ride I
all that happened and uh so now I'm I
wake up
I come too they wake me up in the
hospital
I'm sitting there and
I don't know what happened I'm asking
people like where the hell am I what's
going on and these are strangers like
there's no no one in my family no one
that I know no I have at this point that
I think they just took everything out of
my nose because my mouth is uh it's not
wired shut yet
um it does but it's broken still and
they're not telling me like Hey we're
about to do this
they don't say nothing they say you were
in an accident that's all they say
you're in an accident keep hearing it
I'm like well what does that mean I
don't know where how did I get in an
accident and they don't say anything I
don't know
they didn't
they didn't tell me nothing and then I
would pass out and then I'd wake up
again I don't know how long that went on
for but it kept happening and it turned
out I had two blood clots in my carotid
arteries
um and I did not know at the time but I
guess that can cause like Strokes
I'm not medically educated whatsoever I
don't know anything other than a common
cold uh
so I kept passing out once I'd finally
got to see my family thankfully they got
to
come down and see me and and
um my girl's a nurse so she I'm she's
telling me hey you were you you messed
yourself up skydiving
I'm like there's no way I don't know I
didn't believe her and then I passed out
and then I wake up and I'd ask her again
what happened she said you fell you you
hit the ground hard you can't move
um I also found that I couldn't move my
I I couldn't walk they wouldn't let me
they forcefully held me down and anytime
I tried moving they would come in and
tell me to stop I wouldn't
and they would put straps on my my arms
and hold me down from moving I could not
move they would not allow me to move and
that was so frustrating it was horrible
well uh
when
um
I'm sorry my break the the brackets are
jacking my mouth if I'm talking
um
it goes by and I find out they they tell
me finally what happened they said hey
you were in a skydiving accident you
exploded your L3 and because of that we
put a
a bar I don't know how long it it's
probably it's from my L1
which is kind of near your tailbone
to your L5
in your back and I have a metal bar like
that
I'll never be able to bend over for the
rest of my life to pick anything up
normally
um I mean it's fine it doesn't really
necessarily bug me anymore I'm pretty
used to it now but
it's very frustrating sometimes
they told me I had a metal bar in my
back and I thought that was pretty rough
but I didn't know what it was at the
time and
they said uh and you probably won't be
able to walk
that that sucked that was really rough
to hear
but not so much for me because I'm still
in shock and also please keep in mind at
the time I'm on Dilaudid and 15 other
drugs
I have help there and I didn't realize
that at the time
but I had help from them from my support
team and from
the the substances that they have given
me to help me and since
after that then I met um
the plastic surgery to do my job
he said are you ready and I said sure
and I didn't even know he probably came
in and talked to me I don't remember it
he did I'm sure though because I've met
him since uh I haven't been on anything
these great guys awesome he's a hearing
uh
in Austin uh
it was amazing he's great uh
he uh
reconstructed my mouth it took my jaw
out it's I don't know if you could see
it but it's it's kind of crooked now
um
but he took out a chunk I don't know how
big but my bottom mouth now is crooked
it's pretty probably took out a half
inch or so because it was shattered
and it was probably from my face shield
whenever I smacked the ground
it probably took some severe damage to
went into my face and did a number on my
jaw
um but yeah he put it he he put me back
together
then he wired me up
well whenever I hit the ground I I hit
it so hard
when no one had a speed gun on me they
don't know how fast I was going I mean
probably
I don't know maybe
50 to 60 miles an hour I'll say I
smacked the ground up no parachute it's
horrible uh I hit it so hard a tooth
came up
passed my it came out of my gums I don't
know how because another one went down
and got crushed probably by another
tooth or something
at that point uh they wired it they
wired my shut closed with that tooth out
of my gums
and my jaw would spasm
so so many times after the surgery all
day
and that happened for probably I think
five days ish it was spazzing out
and that would be fine trying to talk or
I'd talk hard because I couldn't move my
jaw
and then it would spazz and I just start
crying it was horrible it's the worst
pain I don't know if
you've ever had a toothache it's
horrible the nerve in your mouths are
really sensitive and it's just
it's it's a bad feeling
um
so I got a wired uh
and it lasted for maybe about five days
I don't know exactly I'd have to double
check how long I had it on but I was in
this this place for a month
and uh they didn't light me up for a
month
they would not let me up and I was
getting freaking frustrated that is so
uncomfortable
going from walking and jumping and being
free and that's the guy to being
literally held down by force if
necessary
and that will be by your loved ones and
then you eventually get frustrated with
your loved ones and you you don't want
to be around them because they're
telling you don't move and all you want
to do is just stand up and you don't
know they tell you you can't walk
the doctors do
and I I want to prove them wrong so I
stand up
and I try but anytime I would they'd
come in and they would threaten to strap
me down that was even worse than not
walking at all so I'd sit back down
usually
anyway I start working in rehab on PT
learning to walk again
and they're really patient with me I'm
very jacked up at this point I I can't
eat really they give me a protein shake
for breakfast lunch and dinner
and they're not good ones I mean you get
what they give you usually it was a
strawberry one was the one I loved the
most it was nasty but it was so much
better than the chocolate and that one
was horrible but you're gonna drink it
if you haven't eaten and they make you
they're not like force Fiji or anything
like that but they they'll bug you until
you eat you make sure you eat
great people
um
yeah they they uh
they start trading me I started doing
like standing things
uh try to move my leg forward which I
still can't do to this day
um
and uh towards the tail end they give me
a release date they say hey you're doing
good in PT you're doing good in OT and
that's occupational therapy not Physical
Therapy it's still kind of physical
therapy but it's more of
um
like weight training like dumbbells and
physical training was more of walk
related like
I'm gonna get you to do like a not a
stair climber but they have their own
version of it it's easier and I'm still
in a walker but
I wouldn't walk anywhere at the
beginning I had to be pushed around a
freaking wheelchair by my my old lady by
them everywhere until like the tail end
until I got my release date then I got
strong enough oh and I learned again how
to walk
once I once I did that
um
they would they would feel comfortable
to leave me because this was a busy
place there's people coming in I've seen
that didn't have half of their face and
they didn't uh
they were in the same some maybe they
didn't fall out of the sky or nothing
uh but
I heard people have normal lives and
just in a car wreck and now they are
missing a leg or
you know there's a real there's one
story in particular that touched me it
was
torturous yet absolutely stunning and
beautiful at the same exact time
um oh sorry this is this is I always
I've never told this story to not cried
so I'm gonna do my absolute best I might
have to pause but
like I said they started I knew what to
do in PT it was the same it was
Clockwork almost the pretty much
relatively same work out so she told me
I want you to do this and I'll be like
okay sounds good and I have another uh
patient I'm gonna go help them is that
all right they would never just leave me
I would say absolutely
that's
that's perfect to paint a picture for
you of the place so it was a big table
with two wrestling mats on it and that's
what you lay on
and uh I was getting good at walking I
have not walked by myself though
um and that was not approved by them and
I was I felt before
so I didn't get up
um she left
and I'm laying there and I'm doing my
workouts
and this kid uh
his kid gets pushed in by his uh I I
don't know if it was his mom or his dad
uh well both of them I mean but I don't
know if what their actual titles were
they looked and appeared as his parents
um but push their push their kid in
there and there's not a teacher or a
instructor with them
um
okay and uh
I'm just working I just minding my own
business I didn't think anything of it I
mean I've seen plenty of kids there
um horrible stories I'm sure but
um I I I've seen him a few days ago and
it made my lady cry just seeing him
because she just we don't have any kids
or anything like that but
we just pictured like man it would be
horrible to be in their situation I mean
God forbid you have a child and then you
have to
you know they're quadriplegic and now
you know and at one point they weren't
that's horrible I don't want to think
about that but
unfortunately that's the situation uh
that these people are were in hopefully
they're doing better but
uh I'm laying on this mat and uh
I'll just say the mom was sitting on uh
it was on my right side she was wearing
a black shirt and the husband was
wearing white one and uh this young kid
maybe the age of 14.
was uh wearing a white one also and uh
he was a quadriplegic for sure like
there's no doubt that this could
I didn't hear a word come out I'd hear
noises uh
his eyes weren't open he was breathing
his parents were talking to him
uh
and that's one thing they were so
positive
and all I could think of was like what I
was going through
the whole time there I was so sad that I
could never walk they told me I wasn't
going to walk again I mean I was walking
but I was walking like a goober man I
was like so
I'm I'm considered crippled right now
and I thought like I'm never going to be
able to run casing again ever in my life
and I'm kind of getting depressed at
this point because I'm working out but
I'm so impatient with my body like I'm
working out and
I'm not walking yet why am I not walking
well I still got a freaking Walker I
gotta get rid of this walker but I gotta
work out
and I keep saying this to me myself
and uh unfortunately uh I didn't I'm
still not better but I have a better
attitude now because thank thankful for
this kid and what I experienced it but
anyway
uh this uh this Mom
is sitting there uh
and while I'm having these thoughts in
my head like it was right as I was
having these thoughts
this uh
this kid
uh he's sitting in his he's he's in a
big wheelchair it's not a standard
wheelchair it's one for special
circumstances like his
and uh these parents don't know who I am
I never said a word to him I was
respecting their space
and what they got going on
uh
but all I could hear was the mom uh
begging
uh
just begging her son and calling him by
his name and I still remember his name
but I don't know if his parents would
like me to say it on this channel so I'm
gonna hold that to myself I still know
his name his full name because his mom
was saying it to him calling him by his
first name and telling him you need to
move your wrist
just move your wrist please just move
your wrist
and I stopped for a second just because
like
I could only imagine
if he would have moved his wrist it
would have changed that Mom's Outlook
like gave that would have been like
winning the lottery
he moved his wrist like just something
anything like it what it doesn't have to
be like this or nothing just twitch at
something
and it would have changed her Outlook
and uh
I I instantly thought like
uh
I I could not I could not believe that I
I fell from 4 000 feet
and
I I I tell people I I've been in a
skydiving accident they say you're a
miracle no no I'm not I I didn't do
anything to doctors in my family did
stuff I laid there on Dilaudid
I didn't do anything I I had absolutely
nothing to do with it I I'm strong
because I had a great support system in
place
and mainly
because of this experience
because at that point I decided that I
don't need to walk at all this kid's not
walking at all
and I get to tell my mom every single
day if I want to see that I love her I
can speak
I can talk
uh I and I have my own thoughts and I
I'm in control of those thoughts
and I say that because in this facility
there are individuals that do not have
control of their thoughts nor how they
speak
and I got to witness that and I was
pretty hideous but I had to lay there
that my instructor usually left me for
about an hour I didn't have a clock near
me but it was about it it was it seemed
like a long time
and I had to listen to this young lady
plead her with her son to just move his
wrist
and I was sitting there I was rooting
for him I wanted him to I was man just
still and you're good you got it it's
cool
and
I'd give anything I don't know if he's
alive but I don't know
I'm sorry this is gross but
um anyway he uh
I don't think he moved his wrist
um
hour goes by I'm I mean I'm a I can't
move I can't leave I'm just listening to
the dad laugh and talk about what
happened
turns out the kid was in a
motorcycle wreck and a dirt bike uh
been in several of those man several
I don't know too many people that have
fell out of the freaking sky and are
living this tell this story
I don't I can't wrap my head around why
I'm alive I don't know why I don't know
I have no idea I don't get it it makes
no sense to me
and this kid who's 14
who has a loving Mom it seemed and a
loving father it seemed uh
had a scar from ear to ear on top of his
head and can't open his eyes anymore
from a dirt bike accident that's
ridiculous like I could not I still
can't understand that uh
it's horrible it's uh I hope that kid's
doing great I mean
I I mean if not I
I wish I could get in contact with him
I'd I'd do anything for them and like
they they saved my life too like they
just played just as much part as my girl
and my mom and those doctors that in my
in my uh rebuilding process but I'm like
do you feel lucky now oh man that's a
that's an understatement I
I feel lucky but I'll tell you man if
something were to happen right now at
this moment in my life I don't have bad
days anymore
I I was very uh
self-centered young man I'm very like
not
I was just selfish man I was very
selfish young man I did what I wanted to
do I mean I made my own lady move so I
can chase my dream Jesus is still doing
her thing but
I did what I wanted to do and it was a
full I completely accept my
responsibility in doing that and she I
mean she didn't see it any gnarly way
you know
she knew I loved it and I mean what are
you gonna do you're going to support
them you know your your family remember
and what they love doing I'm going to do
the same for her I would definitely do
it but
that kid he uh they have no idea
anything about this story then I didn't
go up there and say oh I didn't talk to
him I didn't say nothing to him and I
was too scared
but I was awestruck from that moment on
and I said to myself I don't care if
they take my other leg I don't care if
uh I I lose my sight I don't care I'm
fine like
that kid man like
he he had no he's not he didn't have
anything I didn't see him and I got I
man I pray he has it now
I hope I mean I'd give anything to know
I don't know
I I know his name I haven't looked him
up or anything like that I don't I'm
kind of scared too just like watching my
video I don't I don't really
kind of figure just leave it to
if if it pops up uh
you know
do you regret picking up skydiving
no no I do it again right now if I could
but again like they would
uh USPA won't I mean a legit school or
jump school won't allow me to jump just
because it's a liability like I said if
I deploy
it's gonna tear my back up I mean it's
not a it's not a they train you to make
it as easy as possible when deploying
but it's hard it's a it's a good jolt I
mean you go from 120 to about 20.
so you you lose speed fast like
immediately and
my back won't allow it I have a massive
scar on my back and a lot of metal in my
body now that
I I I I don't know I would love to
skydive man I I say that I would go but
everyone says like Man Logan you're a
miracle you did so many amazing things
again my family did
I wasn't there I didn't have to drive
four hours with the thought of you know
my son being dead
or my girl you know she just uh I think
that
she uh was calling me because that
usually I would get home before she
would be done with work and I'd already
be home she knew I went and jumped but I
I went and jumped many times and came
home and I was at home whenever she
would get home from work you know at
seven uh
I wasn't there
uh she didn't uh
that she didn't get an answer
that day uh
yeah she uh I imagine that was pretty
rough but thankfully it wasn't that far
away your ability to move is improving
yeah slowly very slowly but again uh I
tried I work out hard
uh I don't I get to start PT again they
encourage me to do that I get to it's
been a process to start again but
I get to do it again and uh whenever I
uh start that I'm interested to see what
they set me up or how it compares to how
the
Physical Therapy was
Logan what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
the most important lesson
uh
is that I know I grew up knowing that
everyone's got problems everyone's got
stuff I don't care who you are I mean
I've seen
I've seen grown men
uh men and women and I'm talking
probably grandmothers to to Children man
maybe of nine years old ish you know
boys and girls unfortunately but
everyone's got problems
every single person
but
what that little kid taught me was
you have a lot of stuff that's you
should be grateful for
and unfortunately I had to go through
this whole experience and still I do I
deal with stuff
every day
but
so I had to give yeah just one one bit
of
if I I would say
make sure you uh
you treat every day
and respect what you have because
I've seen many people have normal lives
and
unfortunately uh
it's a real a brutally honest statement
that you can uh
you can lose
something pretty pretty valuable to you
not even
you probably won't even know it
everybody has something terrible going
on in our life but you have good things
too and you just got to find those
and
may not be able to walk perfectly or run
I hope I never come in contact with a
bear because I can't run but I'll tell
you right now
I I can uh come visit you
you know on command
I can come I can go to my mother
I can
speak to her anytime I wish thankfully I
can see
uh and this is
too much maybe but I can uh
I can go to the restroom whenever I want
and I mean I spent a month you know
pissing and defecating all over myself
but I'll tell you what I can now I'm
good I can take care of that and I can
there's people that aren't able to
because of the injury that I suffer from
because of a certain nerve in your back
which controls your lower half
um so thankfully uh uh that that was
never a problem so to speak
but yet that would be it you do have
problems everyone's got problems and
everyone deals with those differently
but please understand you got a lot of
things going for you that you may not
you do take for granted you can you can
speak on command and that's just enough
you don't need anything else trust me
that kid and I promise you that mother
would agree with with what I'm saying
and I hope oh
there's anything I could get for this
and I would love them to hear that uh
because that's one thing I regret is man
I
wish I would have said something to him
to let him know like dude you you guys
changed my life forever
and that stands true today man I don't
care if I can ever walk or run again I
don't care if my other leg just decides
to not work I don't care if I could ever
uh
I'll wire my jaw shut for the rest of my
life man I'm good
I can still you know my I can move my
wrist on command
and your mind works
yeah well it's I'm still working on that
one
it works good enough man
Logan thank you so much for sharing your
story yes sir sorry for the the crying
that's okay you're a lucky man thank you
sir thank you